سكارليت جوهانسون تقاضي
ديزني الممثلة هي واحدة من أكبر
نجوم مارفل التي تزعم أن
ديزني خرقت عقدها عندما
أطلقوا فيلم الأرملة السوداء
على خدمة البث ديزني بلس
وكذلك في المسارح
في نفس الوقت الذي تدعي فيه الممثلة
أنها وعدت بالإفراج عن مسرحية
تقول ديزني إن هناك اقتباسًا لا يستحق
أي شيء على الإطلاق لهذا الملف وأنه
مقتبس مؤلم
في تجاهلها القاسي للوباء السري
19 CNN
كاتب وسائل الإعلام التجارية صريح
بالوتر الذي
انضم إلي الآن لكسر كل
هذا ، هذا أمر مقرف لماذا قد
تهتم سكارليت جوهانسون بهذه ديزني
أصدر هذا الفيلم أه في دور السينما
وعلى منصته المتدفقة ، فإن
المال بهذه البساطة هو المال ، لذلك
عندما تفكر في الأمر بهذه الطريقة
التي تعرفها في هوليوود ، يمكنك عادةً
الحصول على أموالك مقدمًا وسيدفع مبلغ إجمالي كبير
20 مليون دولار ليكون في
فيلم الأعجوبة التالي أو على الأرجح
بالنسبة إلى مستمعي القائمة مثل سكارليت جوهانسون ، فإنك
تحصل على أموالك في النهاية الخلفية مما
يعني أنك تحصل على  نسبة مئوية
من إيصالات شباك التذاكر ، لذلك بالنسبة
لشخص لديه سكارليت جوهانسون ،
ادعت في هذه الدعوى أن راتبها
تم تكوينه في جزء كبير
من إيصالات شباك التذاكر ، فالمشكلة هي
أنه إذا تم وضع فيلم في ديزني بالإضافة إلى
أنها تجادل بأن ذلك أدى إلى تفكيك
الصندوق  المكتب
الذي قام بعد ذلك بتفكيك راتبها ، لذا
فهي الآن تقاضي ديزني لاستعادة
الأموال التي تقول إن ديزني
كلفتها من خلال عرض الفيلم على ديزني بالإضافة إلى
خدمة البث الجديدة الخاصة بهم